a pair of Harvard scientists say a
massive fast-moving visitor to our solar
system may have been a probe sent by an
advanced alien civilization astronomers
were excited to discover the
interstellar object last year it was
named Oh mwah mwah that's Hawaiian for
messenger or scout Tony to Co Pole takes
a look at the evidence behind the
controversial theory he's at New York's
Hayden Planetarium Tony what a story
good morning yeah I hope your son's
watching good morning quick astronomy
lesson what you're looking at here is a
meteorite that came from our solar
system basically our own intergalactic
backyard Oh Mulla Mulla by contrast is
the first observed object to come from
outside of our solar system and get this
once it got here it behaved in ways that
scientists can't quite explain which is
why this team of Harvard scientists is
floating a theory that even they admit
is a little out there when no Mulla
Mulla was discovered last October it was
tumbling past the Sun at a hundred
ninety six thousand miles per hour to
some the reddish object looked like a
cigar others thought it was shaped like
a pancake it looks very different from
objects that we have found in the solar
system
avi Loeb chair of the Harvard University
Astronomy Department said oh mooie-mooie
did not behave like an ordinary asteroid
or give off gas like a comet there
seemed to be an extra force that is
pushing it and it's not clear what this
push is from in an upcoming paper he and
a colleague offer what they call a more
exotic scenario oh mooie-mooie
may be a fully operational probe sent
intentionally to earth vicinity by an
alien civilization according to their
calculations Oh mu a mu ax is less than
a millimetre thin but very wide like a
sail harnessing solar radiation to
propel itself similar to the spacecraft
used by Count Dooku in the Star Wars
films I just want everybody to take that
with a gigantic green of salt
Jackie Feherty is an astrophysicist at
the American Museum of Natural History
she says Oh moolah moolah did not give
off any signals suggesting it was a
spacecraft if you say that the top 10
lists of explanations does not include
alien probe
what is on that list it's a comment or
an asteroid or an asteroid Iraq so then
where is alien civilization on the list
of explanations I don't know real Oh Oh
Ferdy doubts Oh moooo mouaz appearance
means were on the verge of an alien
encounter like the one in the movie
arrival as it stands is a phenomenal
discovery and a really important object
for astronomers to study and for the
public to get excited about it's okay
that it's not alien now oh mooie-mooie
is out of our solar system and we can no
longer see it with our satellites now
ferdi does have a theory for why we keep
coming up with these exotic explanations
as hard as it is to fathom the existence
of aliens it's apparently even harder
for us to fathom the idea that we're
alone Nora
hmm I just like hearing Tony say Oh mom
oh uh oh I like that you could meditate
say that over again Tony thank you